- Welcome to the NBA Mothers
Day Game Halftime Report.
To celebrate the NBA
has us, the NBA Mothers
doing the Halftime commentary, yes!
My name is Draymonda Green,
mother of Draymond Green.
- Lynne Love, Kevin Love's mom! Proud mom!
- You know what I like about your son?
He seems like such a good
boy, such a sweetheart.
- He is, he used to help me clean up,
he's taken out the trash, he was helpin'
me wash the dishes, and
without even asking.
Calls his grandparents every Sunday.
- That's wonderful,
because I can not Draymond
to call me even, you need to--
- Draymond, call your mother!
- Okay!
- She's a lovely lady!
- What're you doing!
- No, but let me not do
that to my son on air.
Draymond is a real sweetheart,
and he tries his hardest.
- He lights up the whole room!
- He takes care of his friends,
he pays for the entire families Netflix,
and that is one thing that
should not be taken for granted.
- He doesn't have to!
- He doesn't.
- He does not have to!
- 'Cause he's a good boy.
- Good boy.
- He's a good boy.
- Fun thing Draymond is he came out
the same size as me, he
slid out like a clone,
so he just messed me up.
(laughs)
Okay, so now the highlights of the game.
So what were some of your
favorite parts of the game?
- The cam and the tron!
- Megatron in the little the thing.
They do like the dance-cam,
and the kiss-cam.
- Oh yeah!
What do you like better, dance or kiss?
- Girl, stop.
- They should make a show about that!
- They should--
- You guys should do a
little segment about that!
- One more highlight
- Mhm.
- One, two, three.
- When the coach was yelling.
- Baby race. Oh.
- Oh my god!
- I loved the baby race.
- Loved the baby races!
I like sometimes when the coaches
get upset 'cause girl--
- They get so mad!
- 'Cause you know they get
their age-rage, so I just.
- Oh you like it.
- It's cute
- Oh.
- It's somethin'
- Okay!
- Yeah, I like it.
- Now it's time for the Southwest
Airlines High Flying Dunk!
- So the slam dunk of the game
was by your son, Kevin Love.
Not only is he a lil' cutie patootie,
I saw on Wendy Williams that
he has a new girlfriend.
- Mhm.
- That is wonderful!
- Girl, stop.
Okay, hold on.
So let's go ahead and bring up the clip!
- [Announcer] Love at the
top of the key, spin--
- Okay, you know, I
know it's controversial,
alright, I get it, I get it,
I know modeling is a job.
- It's not a job.
- It is not.
Okay, so it seems as though
that we are out of
time, and we just wanted
to say thank you to the NBA.
- Thank you!
- Y'know, and make sure
y'all call y'all mothers!
- Call your moms, thank you.
- Girl, I can not take these girls.
- I just, what do we do, what do we do?
- I think the, oh they can, this is when
we're supposed to wave, girl.
- Oh we're waving, okay.
- I don't think they can hear us.
- Lemme just tell ya,
if she even thinks about getting pregnant.
(upbeat music)